so yeah i got approached by a very rich
businessman who said do what do you want
to do because you will not lie down
you're like
you keep standing up like some like some
stupid boxer who doesn't know when the
battle is finished
and i said well i should do something
media and i actually mentioned you
because you're actually responsible for
some of this as i told you before and
again i apologize
you know and um
he said no no you need a political party
he said they'll only ever listen to you
if you have a political party
yeah what what signs are you seeing like
i i've just sort of come around to
to that the the same liberals
just need they don't have to change
their beliefs at all i mean i wrote a
whole book defending liberalism but they
have to ally
with the moderates on the right which i
think is most of america at this point
just freedom loving people and we can
debate about tax rates and all that kind
of stuff do you see
some signs that the that the decent
liberals are waking up and fighting some
of the woke stuff because there's not
much here
there's just not much it's a bit it's
it's a very um it's a very difficult
subject for politicians certainly to get
involved we've got a conservative party
here which is i mean they're not even
vaguely conservative they're almost the
socialist party on their own
and then the opposition party is even
more left-wing than that
so we're in we're in difficult difficult
times
actually because it's an attack on
everything isn't it it's not
con um you know it's an attack on values
uh love of family love of country it's
an attack on all the things that are
were okay to be you know to to love and
and we had this horrible murder a few
days ago in london of this
uh girl and then there was a vigil held
for her and the police
got um too too involved really because
they
they've turned we've basically turned
into a police state here and within
minutes it turned into a leftist
demonstration so we're now getting
we're getting what you have in portland
starting
to the rumblings of in london screaming
neurotic lunatics going on like that one
minute they'll go who streets are
streets and then they'll be on to
[ __ ] the police kill the police they
just they don't know what they're
screaming about but they're angry
yeah are they organized in any way i
mean this is the big debate in america
is antifa just an idea
like is andy tracking this andy no is is
that why he's there right now
yeah andy was there the other day yeah
he's checking it um
but i don't think they're that organized
i think social media is helpful isn't it
for crazy people with crazy views to get
together
so what are they even protest i mean
from a british perspective what are they
protesting
or they just don't i i i went to the
protest
so i was like i need to know what these
guys are upset about
and i couldn't work it out they were
just screaming it was one thing to the
next you know
it was meant to be about this this
dreadful crime this murder of this woman
but it became about something else it
was like let's kill the police and it
was acab
all cops are bastards and it's like well
are they
you know i don't understand no one knew
what was going on they were just
marching up and down the street and then
they went and lay down in trafalgar
square for a while
i think basically none of either they
weren't paying attention at school
or they're not interested in history
yeah
how do you think the lockdowns fit into
this because
you guys are still in pretty severe
lockdowns right now
we are in severe lockdown no one's
paying any attention to it though it's
so british
it's like yes we might they whenever
they poll the british people they're
like are you all in lockdown are you
supportive of it and the brit's like yes
absolutely we're supportive and then i
walk out my door and
down the street and i look at on the
window it says stay at home protect the
nhs save lives and then you look
downstairs and people having a drinks
party
so it's um it's it's do as i uh say not
do as i do
yeah so all right you're a radical
right-wing
guy trying to defend extreme right-wing
extreme
winger trying to defend liberalism so
you walk in through the fire
you decide okay i'm not going to be
canceled i'm going to see what happens
and then how did you make the shift to
say well i'm actually going to freaking
start a political party and run
for office it's one thing to survive it
but then to really say i'm going in and
i'm going to do something
well it's just such a gap so like we did
um i mean after this we did i had a
feeling that there was a
large constituency of people that just
weren't being allowed to express
themselves
so um there's just this huge freedom of
speech hole
so i thought that needs mending because
we have to have a proper debate about
everything including lockdowns actually
weirdly because they have they haven't
been
talked about they've just been you must
accept that lockdowns are a good thing
and there's no debate allowed so yeah i
got approached by a
very rich businessman who said do what
do you want to do
because you will not lie down you're
like you keep standing up like some like
some stupid boxer who doesn't know when
the battle is finished
and i said well i should do something
media and i actually mentioned you
because you're actually responsible for
some of this as i told you before and
again i apologize
you know and
he said no no you need a political party
he said they'll only ever listen to you
if you have a political party
so weirdly we started the political
party and um
things suddenly the culture became
important again to our conservative
government because they're trying to
hold me off on their
on what is what it would essentially be
the liberal side of things but it's now
the sort of extreme far right as on
lovely miracles yeah so this morning i i
read the i went to the reclaim website
and you you
basically write an open letter
describing why you started the party and
and what the beliefs are and uh i
thought it was quite
perfect actually um can you can you
describe some of the principles
these again these crazy right-wing
liberal principles that you
that you're defending well i think it's
like
it's really simple i'm defending an idea
so it's not really about me
anyway so that you know you should be
you should be able to protect yourself
from attack if you believe in freedom of
speech you believe in
everybody's freedom to speak right and
um
so that's what i stand for i stand for
the the biggest and broadest debates to
be had possible
and um then what i've done sort of
practically is i've commissioned
which is actually going to be quite big
news in england soon which is going to
shock them i've commissioned a
full and huge legal review of our
of all of the legal impingements on
freedom of speech because you know
you've got your equality act going
through and what's it called hr one or
whatever it was going through in america
now we had this [ __ ] they did this in
like 2010 in the uk we have our own
equality act where people are
have protected characteristics and
they're not they're not equal under the
law
so we all of this stuff is really
dangerous legislation
and um i commissioned a full review and
some very eminent
top top top people who have put together
a suggestion for the british people and
for the parliament
about how we can lose division in
society
but it's weird when you try and lose
division you tend to attract divisive
people
yeah it seems to be are are you worried
that in essence
you'll sort of like just at a
like practical level that you'll sort of
split the conservatives because some
conservatives will go with you
the rest will stay with the
conservatives and then ultimately you
just help labor and the labor party
has as you sort of said before kind of
gone off the rails
i think the conservative candidate in
london is not he's a he's such a sweet
guy as well which i find
so difficult because he's a really
lovely guy but he's not for some reason
he's not
creating the right waves so um
no i think what i want and what would be
best would be
for me and siddique our mayor
who likes to race bait on a daily basis
um to debate and talk about our capital
city and you know what's his vision for
it and
because you know he's he's got this is
called the commission for diversity in
the public realm
he's got and it sounds lovely dude so it
always sounds lovely
it always sounds lovely but it's just
like let's tear down all our statues
and um he's already had to kick one
member off he's an avowed
surprisingly for the left extreme left
and a vowed anti-semite
who would have thought it shocking in
the labor party i can't believe it
are you it's weird isn't it right the
people that call you racist they are the
exact thing they accuse you of
so um he's uh i've sort of lost my
my train now so in essence though you
you want it you want to debate sadiq
khan and yeah and
do you sense that that could happen or
or is it a pipe dream i mean
will he do it who knows man
we've got um we've got a pretty cool
campaign
uh on thursday we're gonna start um
dropping the
you know some of the more importantly
controversial
but needing to be said statements to
london i mean look at the end of the day
london is like the cathedral of woke
like any metropolitan center so i
for me the most important thing is just
to
raise the voice for the people who don't
get to speak that's it it's the only
reason i do it
so all right so you guys are seeing some
violence in london
with sort of sort of newish violence
there's the lockdowns
we were mentioning right before we
started recording you know we have a
couple friends in common douglas murray
and
and
peter lloyd and a few other people peter
basically has fled
london and everyone that i talk to
that's in london is really not happy
about what's going on there what
what besides the free speech stuff has
sadiq khan
done wrong well he's um he's a he's
what has he done right really is the way
he starts all right
he's terrible we've got a surging knife
crime
problem in london and then that's made
almost unsolvable because of
the way that he stokes racial tensions
between people so
you know he calls you a racist if you
try and deal with knife crime he would
call you a racist
he's um he's obviously trying to tear
down all of our
um of our shared history and um you know
he what did he say the other day he said
something like there's just no reason
why there should be 65
of these people should be white men
working in this particular field and
you're like
hang on a minute dude just slow down
this country is 83 or 85 white
of course it's going to be more white
people you know he's
it's this very specific demonization of
white people
and fortunately he has a huge
constituency of white people who also
hate themselves as well you know the
sort of white
urban liberals and it's it's like
it's really sad because most of the
working class in the united kingdom
would usually vote labor
you know they would but labor don't
represent labor
they don't represent laborers and they
don't represent actually the important
things which are class
issues in this country you know britain
is constantly infrequent i think
after new zealand and i can't remember
where else we are the most tolerant
country on earth you know in terms of
like tolerance of intermarriage and all
this sort of stuff so i don't know why
at the center of the altar of woke our
mayor is trying to turn around and go
you know what guys
you're all racists it's like come on man
it's 2021. we've got to get a new story
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell